starting pitcher for the cubs is indeed
mr davies four pitch mix he'll lean
heavily on that sinker change-up
combination
outside corner ring them up good start
oh boy
reaching that time here's rizzo picking
it up
davies gets over and there's two away
on the ground there's matt duffy who
gets a start at second base tonight
and he makes the play
[Applause]
and a nice easy inning for zach davies
mali's pitched awfully well against the
cubs his last two times out now he had a
start earlier in the year where he
pitched against
the cubs and things did not go so well
last two times out he's pitched awfully
well against him and he's pitched
well in this ballpark popped up
mali off-balance last moment
did he call off otto and then start to
look away
bottle seems stunned
brian gets that upstairs heat naked
tracks it down
patrick wisdom batting
that's it pretty well out towards right
center back
turning and that's into the ivy
and then disappears and stopping at
third
is rizzo
so now they're loaded
turned on the right aquino extends and
makes the grab
smashes into the ivy give it a good ride
by hayward
and aquino helps maui's cause to leave
him loaded
four straight days with dingers for joey
bottom
bottom gets into a breaking ball shot
deep to left
he did it again it's five straight games
with a joey vom homer he has tied the
all-time reds franchise record
his 18th of the year one nothing
reds i mean this is a backdoor hook
that's off the plate
and he just risks that ball out of the
ballpark
and knew it when he hit it
so india uses his eyeballs his knowledge
of the zone and he gets a
reds base runner winker
launches to deep center and it skips to
the ivy but it's a free ball
india given the wave in third base throw
in eaton in the outfield grass
india crosses standing jesse
winker thunders a double to center field
scores india from first base reds two
cubs nothing o'malley threw three
and he has not recorded a strikeout
2-2 to hayward swinging
swing in the miss consecutive case for
tyler malley
that was the split away he's beyond the
cut he breaks
and the pitch to right aquino has to go
back and he makes the play
full extension barely keeping his
balance
mid-sprint reds lead at 2-0
single scores in the second and third
india gets that one through
on base again twice in three plate
appearances
tonight
winker lines it into the right field
corner india steams through second
challenges for third stop sign there
and winker slows into second base back
to back
doubles for jesse winker feels like
stevenson's rather do
tyler stevenson cranks that to left
center
that's down and kicks off the wall india
scores
winker jogs in stevenson the second the
tag
and he's out the reds double their lead
it's four
to nothing you said he was due i think
he cashed the payment
that was a rocket stay inside long
enough
he's going to get you it's a heck of an
effort on the slide by the big fella
he took the umpire phil cussey out
that's for sure
he has fought through and he finds
himself in the sixth inning
throwing a shutout
wisdom hit it hard a couple of times in
fact all three times
india second one farmer on the first in
time
double play well the defense gets it
done and helps mali's cause he is
through
six scoreless innings and the new
pitcher
literally is a new pitcher for the reds
luis sessa cessa comes in as the first
day in as a reds
pitcher and he will take the mound here
that slider send to left
winker 2-2
check swing he went no appeal needed
cesar's first strikeout as a red two up
two down
to winker luis sessa
in his cincinnati reds debut a one
two three seventh inning dylan maples
been fairly busy here
in recent days getting a good bit of
work he's on for the 24th time he has a
2.03 era
first pitch hey eugeo suarez bombs one
to right center field
off the ivy sprints into second base
takes it standing with a booming double
way and he gets hit by pitch again
that's 15 times he's been hit by pitch
only jonathan india
has been hit by pitch more in the
national league
oh my goodness nowhere near the zone to
walk the bases
loaded for shogo akiyama
bases loaded way in and there is the run
now you called for cowboy and akiyama
takes it on the leg that pushes home a
eugeo suarez a five-run
lead for the reds well i thought he
showed great patience there
[Music]
reaching that one popped up duffy
rizzo duffy
number two
the glove of maples the shortstop picks
it up
and throws them out 1-6-3
that's a good job managing that right
there time for another
reds debut is the left-hander
justin wilson carry the one
back door strike three but that's what i
remember
about justin wilson
[Music]
cutter to india who pumped
not there at first they did get the out
at second base
indy on the charge nice exchange and
throw
so the reds have their lead off man on
for joey vado
[Applause]
bottle gets the pitch down low
and sticks it in the seats again when he
went deep
in the second inning you saw the raised
index finger
he said that's one it's
back to back games with two homers joey
votto is the third red
to have seven homers in five games
ever jay bruce in 2010
johnny bench in 1972
and joey votto in 20-21
a four-pitch walk in a seven
run game in the ninth
[Music]
line to left center field that's in the
gap and that'll go all the way to the
wall this will score at least one more
farmer's home
and around to third base getting a stop
sign as naiquin as akiyama
motors into second with an rbi doubles
now eight nothing reds
second rbi of the night for sugo ryan
hendrix
is on the pitch
duffy into score that's right
comes on the board waiting at 02.
save it first end to score is bodhi and
it's 8-2
[Applause]
shot to right naked
squeezes it and the reds
win it